okay so there was Zero intimacy after
Scarlet we've had sex since she's been
born I can say we've had sex about four
or five times since Scala was born okay
that's fair yeah it's because of me
because I don't want to take any chances
right now yeah
you better talk to Bilal because he
knows
how I'm pregnant
he looks real confident over there he
could he could do it really good yeah I
know what you mean okay that was some
shade shida just threw it you below
she's Queen shade oh my God
okay has anybody else's sex life cooled
[Laughter]
Tyson Patrick oh yeah it's gone up
better now it's better now I don't know
yeah yeah it's better now that you're
pregnant yeah yes yes yes
would you say it's the best now yeah
it's insane interesting okay
Alexa practice we're blessed yeah but he
doesn't I think after practicing
something should yeah like you want to
see something right we've been apart for
so long I'm like let's enjoy each other
for a little bit yeah how long is a
little bit like uh you know two years
that's long and you're gonna have two
years I'm 37 by the way I know that
right if you remember the time you don't
control time yeah well you never know
how long after you really start trying
it'll take thank you my friend tried for
years and and years and years and you
better start trying now we don't see eye
to eye when it comes to this he knows
that this is a very sensitive topic
because he sees this one way and I see
it a whole different way
[Music]
foreign